today I'm taking my cue from Italy a
country that takes home cooking family
and fresh vibrant flavors extremely
seriously the Italians are brilliantly
using good food to bring people together
as well as being delicious today's
dishes are also really quick and easy to
make leaving you more time to sit down
and enjoy them with your friends and
family first up in my ultimate Italian
food a deliciously tasty breakfast of
fennel sausage frittata
it's light fluffy and it smells
incredible next a lunch to Whiskey away
to Italy in the first thoughtful grilled
sardines with gremolata and also pasta
salad fresh clean almost if we sat on
him Alpha Coast
and as boys joined forces as Jack helps
me cook an incredible dinner with dishes
from the length and breadth of Italy
mmm
starter from the south quick fig Jam
crostini with creamy burrata
from the north a hearty slow-cooked beef
cheek Ragu with Papa Deli well when you
cook this for your girlfriend one day
just tell her where you got the recipe
for money promise promise
rounding off with a Tuscan inspired
dessert luxurious espresso panna cotta
with cinnamon hazelnut brittle Maggie
how is it Danny it's so tasty follow
these ultimate recipes and you too can
Embrace breakfast lunch and dinner the
passionate Italian way
starting with breakfast a fennel sausage
frittata
the exciting thing about frittata is the
fact there's no set recipe because it's
basically eggs whatever else you have
left
for me the secret of a good frittata is
in the sausage nice hot pan onions in
getting this on the onions Heat
nice and high
season
fennel seeds to give the onions
a really nice flavor everyone's used to
cooking sausages whole
but it's a really nice way of using them
to take them out of their thin skin
what we're going to do is crumple all
that wonderful spicy fennel sausage into
the onions it's going to release all
that flavor a lot quicker
pretty important to keep that gas nice
and high and the longer you caramelize
the sausage the more flavor
you're gonna gain
six whole eggs give your eggs a really
good mix
flat leaf parsley a staple in Italian
cooking chop it
quite rough
some Parmesan
it gives a really nice seasoning fresh
pepper
a little touch of salt
and then get it in there
run your fork through it so when you
slice it
no one's complaining they've got less
sausage
I'm gonna make it even more Italian by
topping it with some Buffalo mozzarella
dry it and then slice it nice and thinly
twist it
mozzarella in
and then finally finish it without
pounds and cheese get the top just as
tasty as it is the bottom
the frittata needs three and a half to
four minutes under a red Hot Grill to
achieve the best results always ensure
your oven or grill are preheated to the
perfect temperature this is the thing I
love about Italian cooking it's about
sharing but always focusing on the
ingredients look at that
I mean it's incredible a little shake
the pan to make sure it comes out and
then spatula underneath and just leave
it
it's light
fluffy and it smells incredible and that
for me is a dream come true it's amazing
how far you can take six eggs and two
sausages
wow
spicy fennel sausage frittata My
ultimate Italian breakfast it's a
cracking start to the day
foreign
[Music]
food puts a premium on fantastic
ingredients cooked simply
here's a bit of help on what to look for
when you're buying some of the key
ingredients for today's lunch and dinner
for dinner tonight I'll be cooking value
for money beef cheek
this large meaty muscle can cost as
little as two pound of Pop from your
local butcher but the rewards of cooking
it with a little love and Patience are
Bountiful
slash fried the meat from this
hard-working muscle is very tough but
slow braising will transform into four
Falls of melt in your mouth
deliciousness
I'll be using this cheeky cut for a
deliciously cheap Italian dinner that
will feed a whole family
[Music]
burrata one of Italy's most recent
cheesy exports was invented back in the
1920s from a need to make use of the
little scraps of mozzarella left in the
cheese making vat
shreds are mixed with cream and encased
in a hand spun mozzarella pouch
this luxurious rich pugal and delicacy
is now becoming more popular in our
supermarkets
[Music]
if I had to choose one herb synonymous
with Italy this would be it basil the
perfect partner for tomato based dishes
or pounded with Parmesan and pine nuts
for a delicious pesto
[Music]
Basil's soft silky aromatic leaves will
bring a taste of the Mediterranean to
any dish they touch and I'll be using it
in my ultimate Italian lunch
in much of Italy lunch is traditionally
seen as the most important meal of the
day and for a food assassination that's
really saying something whenever or
whatever Italians cook they always put a
premium on straightforward fresh food
prepared simply that's why Italian food
is so brilliant for the home cook for my
ultimate Italian lunch I'm cooking
scrummy sardines topped with a fragrant
gremolata dressing but first a
deliciously fresh orzo pasta salad this
is one of the Hidden Delicacies of
Italian pasta also because 90 of the
time it's always hidden in a soup or a
brothel minestrone and it looks like
large grains of rice but once they
absorb that water they double in size
It's a pasta that needs a lot of help
season it nicely pinch of salt a splash
of extra virgin olive oil fresh bay leaf
into the boiling water and that bay leaf
really helps to flavor the pasta give
you a little pan
turn left and right that stops any pasta
sticking to the bottom and the secret
behind cooking any pasta is having a
nice gentle rolling boil you just have
the gas up where the outside of the pan
is just rolling and all that also is
tumbling over each other gently boiling
past the rapidly tends to destroy the
outside texture it doesn't take the
marinade or the vinaigrette or the sauce
for the dressing parmesan Twist of fresh
pepper the zest of the lemon I'll
squeeze your lemon in there through your
fingers to catch all those seeds bring
that together with some extra virgin
olive oil
pine nuts taste delicious toasting them
just elevates them
after eight minutes my orzo is perfectly
al dente
train it a little bit of cold water
through it close the cooking process
down but stops it from going mushy it's
the size of pumpkin seeds now a drizzle
of olive oil and into the vinaigrette
whilst it's still warm
just above room temperature because the
wall with a pasta the more it absorbs
the vinaigrette and now some texture
rocket not finely chopped
on the fresh basil as well
roll them up like a big fat cigar slice
in half
and then chop the basil
crunch just sprinkle the toasty pine
nuts
it looks like a plate of jewels glistens
it's delicious very fragrant also pasta
salad now for sardines incredibly
healthy and absolutely delicious grilled
never ever be intimidated on looking for
fresh fish it's about the condition of
the fish Bright Eyes fresh gills nice
bright red interior and the firmness of
the flesh almost you could stand the
fish up on its own it needs to be that
fresh the best way to get flavor into
sardine just to grill it light seasoning
olive oil
and just roll the seasoning around
get your Rosemary peel off a few of the
little shards at the end so it's a
little bit sharp push the Rosemary in
almost like a Threading makes them so
much more flavoursome
they'll be scared of those fine little
bones I remember growing up with
sardines tin sardines you didn't tongue
your nose up at the bone once The
Griddle pan starts to smoke lightly
drizzle and then sardines on
two and a half for three minutes each
side
now for the gremolata a vinaigrette that
sits beautifully well on the sardines
freshly fastly just run the knife once
nothing worse when you over chop parsley
and all that delicious flavors left on
the board the zest and juice of an
orange and a lemon
you can turn them now
grandma that's about fragrance natural
flavors
brilliant for grilled Meats as well a
little touch of salt
and pepper
and then olive oil just to bring it
together
the garlic I almost want to be like a
secret weapon in there
raise it
bring that together you've got a very
fresh clean gremolata almost if we sat
on the Amalfi Coast
off
then once the sardines are still nice
and warm and just thinly coat gremolata
I'd like to pass in the garlic to sit on
top and that's citrus from the lemon and
the orange to sort of dive underneath
see why Italian cuisine rides on the
freshest and the simplest execution
they allow their ingredients to become
the hero
not the chef
also salad with stunning grilled
sardines
wherever you eat this dish it will fill
your senses with the sun and the Sea of
the Mediterranean delicious
[Music]
one of the things I really admire about
the Italian approach to food is not just
how they cook but how they eat and enjoy
food too it's very very relaxed and it's
all about sharing great food with
friends and family our home life is
pretty hectic so when we're all at home
together we try and have a bit of
Italian Spirit at Meal Time
right my ultimate Italian dinner
this is one of the kids favorites
and I've got Jack helping me in the
kitchen wow
[Music]
we're hoping to wow the family with an
amazing quick fig Jam crostini with
creamy burrata and the hearty Maine of
beef cheek Ragu with Papa Deli Big
Cheese just think the size of your
little cheeks yeah imagine the size of a
cow with them and the cheek is right
underneath here yeah
um
yeah I always give him a really nice
season with salt and pepper on there
please so beef cheeks very cheap they
cut that takes sort of a long time to
cook yeah but give it a bit of love let
it cook in the oven it comes out like a
dream a little touch
of oil in the pan what we want to do is
get them really nicely colored shed see
it into the pan oh cool layaway
see what that is
um
[Music]
sitting at the dock of the
Beach
and then I want the onion chunky because
we're going to cook it for like
three three and a half hours so you go
down
down
[Music]
and then again there and there so it
doesn't overcook
so a really good color on the cheeks
like that so how do you cook these at a
restaurants if they take so long they go
in the oven literally half past six
seven o'clock in the morning three and a
half four hours we're ready for lunch
and the longer you leave them in their
juices yeah and the cooking liquor the
better three guys close the garlic good
onions in and garlic in please nice
where's your Bailey there it is
get those onions and that garlic really
nicely colored
put the cheeks back in place right red
wine in cool okay the red wine is going
to deglaze the pan so deglaze will
basically sort of rinse all that flavor
off the bottom of the pan yeah okay
because that's going to make the most
amazing sauce
now you could use tomato puree but
chopped canned tomatoes you'll make a
much better sauce I'm gonna top that
with some stock so the secret of
braising is having little of the meat
exposed and 90 of it submerged see them
now yeah
they're like little crocodile heads
popping up out the water turn the gas
off and leave the lid just off at the
end there if we had to cover it
completely the steam hits the top yeah
the lid and all that water comes running
back solar still that's right in the
oven
140 150 for about three and a half to
four hours good job
Boom for pudding I'm making one of my
absolute favorite Italian desserts Banna
cotta with that quintessentially Italian
flavoring espresso
start by immersing two leaves of gelatin
in cold water and leave to soak
into a small saucepan add caster sugar
cream milk
sugar and a shot of good strong coffee
gently bring to a simmer and remove from
the hob
[Music]
squeeze out the soaked gelatin leaves
and stir into the hot cream into a
completely dissolved
pour your cream mixture into a jug and
fill your molds just short of the rim
rinsing your molds in cold water before
filling will make it easier to get your
panna cotta out once it's set
[Music]
leave in the fridge for at least two to
three hours or overnight
[Music]
to make your cinnamon hazelnut brittle
pour caster sugar into a pan and cook
over medium Heat
until the sugar melts to a deep golden
brown
[Music]
scatter toasted hazelnuts into the
caramel
dust with ground cinnamon and leave to
set at room temperature
when your panna cotta is firm given each
mold a quick dip into boiling water
should ensure a perfect stress-free exit
onto the plate
thank you
[Music]
dress with a Shard of crunchy hazelnut
brittle nothing could be so deliciously
elegant
right Captain Jack quick run through
Panna cottas are nearly set beef cheeks
I need it cooked we're going to now do
the Fig and brighter crostini oh okay
let's take the figs we're gonna make a
nice slightly spicy fig Jam take off the
tops yep in half and each half into
three sugar a touch of salt in there
okay we're making a jam but we don't
want a bit too sweet and then these
little babies
what are they
ah what's the shape stars star
underneath taken from the fantasy plant
yeah and when you're drying like that so
intensifies the flavor really important
to count how many put in there okay yeah
so one two three four five so they're
just there from flavors and take them
out that's right secret here let's get
that camera going so when I hear a jam I
don't think of caramel no but this is a
very fast champ caramel's starting to
color
I want you very carefully to drop the
figs in there good
so the juice out of the figs
is starting to break down the camera
you know what that is I'll sweep it in I
love that on my challenge you've got
that sort of sweet and sour flavor leave
that cooking for three four minutes
now let's slice out chapata in Italian
crostini means little bits of toast but
it could be made out of leftover
baguette sourdough or any crusty open
textured bread we're staying
authentically Italian with ciabatta
season them and then drizzle a little
touch of olive oil on there both sides
really important because we're going to
grill the bread push it down
it's a lovely very lovely take it off
with the chapata toasted we need to
carefully extract the star and these
pods from our piping hot fig Jam
my Jack we've got one little bugger to
find oh no
is it there yes it is right now we've
got the green light to crush
[Music]
skins disintegrated in that caramel that
looks so nice
oh Jack carefully spreads the crostini
with our hot fig Jam I can unveil the
last element to our starter the creamy
Italian specialty burrata
my little money bags
delicious this looks fun doesn't it
we need to season them lightly drizzle
over a little olive oil and dust them
with lemon zest imagine that sat there
and you tear some of that off and you
stick it on top of that and
back to the main course to match our
hearty beef cheeks I've chosen to use
Papa Deli rule number one when cooking
pasta
salt in first salt and first good olive
oil in
pasta in
twist it round so you don't break it no
bring that back up the ball that's going
to take that through for four minutes
flat leaf parsley scrunch it up for me
yep and chop him now wait to see these
beef cheeks beauties
look at them
they're very soft tiny I'm going to
taste
um
it's so good
yeah you just dribbled on your jumper
really
right drain the pasta
salt pepper
pasta little drizzle
of olive oil
I'm going to put your fresh pasta nicely
chopped nicely chopped
in
this is the magic bit okay you take a
little Ladle of the juice
put that at the bottom
cook
the pasta
on top of that sauce
honestly oh my gosh your sisters are
going to love you even more now you know
what about when you cook this for your
girlfriend one day uh just tell her
where you got the recipe from William
promise promise I don't want you
stealing Daddy's Thunder
one
beautiful jaw on there two beautiful
Jaws on there
and then the third job and then you go
over
with the source how cool is that
delicious you've got the burrata
and I've got the cheeks
let's go
[Music]
don't be cheeky get it
my ultimate Italian dinner
quick fig Jam crostini with creamy
borata a main course of slow cooked beef
cheek Ragu with Papa Deli and for
pudding espresso panna cotta with
cinnamon hazelnut brittle
a stunning meal to bring the whole
family together in the best Italian
tradition
[Music]
s
[Music]
how creamy is that it's a small cheap
check please oh yes please of course you
can
Maggie how is it darling
what's your favorite part I I really
like the cheeks
[Music]
not funny is when somebody grabs the
other cheek start worrying well the
right one
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
[Music]
today I'm putting together a fantastic
breakfast lunch and dinner with an
American flavor I've traveled throughout
the United States for my work and as
well as having some shockingly bad meals
over there I've also had some brilliant
ones and right now the U.S food scene is
really vibrant lots of new talented
young chefs incorporating new flavors
into the dishes and Reinventing American
Classics taking my cue from some of the
best this is my ultimate American Home
Cooking first up for breakfast my take
on a U.S Diner classic ex-bage with
crispy hash browns and Smoky sweet bacon
for lunch the mighty American Caesar
salad with brittle chicken breast and a
big bold dressing followed by peanut
butter and jam cookies to die for time
for a little drink and middle daughter
Holly joins me in the kitchen you put
yours in there I'll put mine here sad
we're creating an American Feast with
barbecue style beef brisket crunching
like coleslaw and spicy sweet potato
wedges
this is my ultimate American food
breakfast lunch and dinner first up eggs
baked in hash browns
The Secret of a great hash brown
other potatoes
I prefer using really nice waxy potatoes
they cook better but more importantly
hold themselves together
We're Not Gonna slice the onion all the
potatoes we're actually going to grate
them the potatoes get really nice and
crispy I mean seriously crispy now the
onion
that way you get that nice balance of
that onion flavor running through every
little Shard of potato
[Music]
season with salt pepper olive oil and km
give that a really good mix through
squeeze
all that water out
and look at all that juice we squeeze it
out there really important the more
liquid you remove the crispier your hash
browns will be
nice large pan put that on
CE the Pan's hot pour in a good glug of
olive oil
[Music]
that sound confirms
how important it is to have your pan
nice and hot
so seals
the grated potato onion together
so take the spoon
and just
Pat it down what we're trying to do now
is get it really nice and compact
going around the outside of the pan with
a little flecks of butter you just slip
them down the back gently
and that gets the onions caramelized
here's a great tip for turning your hash
browns over quick and easy take a plate
place it on top and just
flip it over
and then slide it back in
very quickly
you see the color
we've got on there now
got that nice crispy texture
of the potato I'm going to use the hash
brown as a bed for my baked eggs
cracking your eggs nice and gently just
a little sprinkling of the can
to make the eggs a little bit spicy then
into a preheated oven for six to eight
minutes meanwhile onto my bacon and I'm
giving it a classic American twist now
one thing I could never get my head
around when I first started eating lots
of American breakfast was the sweetness
from the bacon I've grown up to love
that combination of smoky sweet flavors
and it's so easy pan on and simply heat
olive oil brown sugar salt and pepper
and butter bacon in and as it Cooks it
becomes irresistibly caramelized and
golden brown Turf of gas
and my glazed bacon
absolutely ready beautiful
now my hash browns and baked eggs are
ready
beautiful just
keep your spatula underneath there
onto your plate and that bacon
sets Beauty on top of the baked eggs and
that hash brown underneath and
see why the best breakfast in the world
are always in America
this is an All-American superhero offer
breakfast eggs bacon hash browns with
glazed bacon
[Music]
next I'm showing you a fantastic
American inspired lunch and dinner
[Music]
to go to the US to buy the ingredients
here's a closer look at the key ones
first up it's beef brisket a cheap cut
from the breast of the cow
it's underused in the UK but loved by
American cousins and used for incredible
delicates like Pastrami and succulent
salt beef
the key to beef brisket is to cook it
low and slow to make it tender and I've
got a delicious barbecue style recipe
for dinner
[Music]
next sweet potatoes as American as apple
pie
sometimes called yams in the USA they're
native to the tropical Americans they
cook quicker than standard potatoes
they're packed with nutrients and have a
fantastic sweet flavor whether you mash
them bake them or roast them but I
really love the simple sweet potato
wedges I'm making for dinner
[Music]
the ultimate American staple has to be
peanut butter and more than half the
peanuts grown in the U.S are used to
make it
I love it both crunchy or smooth and not
just spread on bread it's fantastic and
savory sauces like Satay or even in
desserts like the peanut butter and jam
cookies I'm making for lunch
the main course will be a crispy Big
Caesar salad but the first job are my
peanut butter and jam cookies
[Music]
start with the cookie dough simply
combine muscovado sugar peanut butter
and butter until light and fluffy
then add your egg a splash of milk
vanilla seeds and beat again until
smooth
[Music]
together salt baking powder and flour
and mix until thoroughly combined
[Music]
in floured hands roll the cookie dough
into golf ball sizes flatten and create
an indent with your finger fill with
half jam and half peanut butter
place the cookies on a tray lined with
baking paper and bake in a preheated
oven for 10 to 12 minutes
before serving
[Music]
next job main course and my take on an
iconic American salad first made almost
a century ago Caesar salad is definitely
a classic but the trick to keeping
dishes like this modern and relevant is
to tweak them but not lose what made
them brilliant in the first place here's
my version for the ultimate American
lunch my first twist is in the dressing
for me the most important part of the
Caesar salad is that dressing
Rich creamy slightly spicy
Begin by making a basic mayonnaise
start off with the egg yolks in just
a little spoon Dijon and then a little
splash of red wine vinegar
start whisking
once you've got that nice slightly
thickened texture
drizzle in your olive oil
should fall through
your whisk it's like a nice thick
double cream texture
beautiful
now take the Mayo to another level with
Anchovies and crushed garlic now chop up
the anchovies and the garlic together
so we almost want that to be like a
really nice
puree then grated Parmesan lemon juice
that will make the dressing
citrusy
lighter in color and then a little
splash of water
and
now
all of a sudden it transforms that
mayonnaise into an amazing
delicious
light dressing
nice
next job the croutons and I like using
crusty bread for extra Crunch and just
dice up your bread season with salt and
pepper then add to a hot pan with olive
oil and Fry give that a really nice toss
as the croutons start to turn golden
simply great on a generous amount of
Parmesan cheese keep them rolling around
stop them from sticking together think
of that really nice cheesy delicious
Crouton and now they're out
now for the fun job assembling the
Caesar salad starting with Romaine
lettuce
and don't slice the lettuce
too thinly
a squeeze of lemon on with half of that
gutsy anchovy Mayo dressing
saving some to coat your chicken later
then sprinkle half your croutons
give that a really nice mix
salad in it's all beautifully dressed
add the remaining croutons and finish
with a good grating of Parmesan cheese
that for me is a perfect season salad
however I'm going to take it to another
level and grill a stunning
some breasts start by preheating your
griddle pan then butterfly your chicken
breast simply slice from the thin end
towards the thick bit of the breast put
the knife to the work and literally just
open up
now that's how we butterfly a chicken
breast so therefore it will cook twice
as quick and just nice and moist in the
center
season the chicken on both sides with
salt and ground pepper lay your chicken
breast onto the grill
[Music]
never oil the grill because you're
absolutely ready to cook the chicken now
turn them over
useful
cook for three to four minutes on each
side until the chicken's got those
lovely Stripes from The Griddle which
adds a gorgeous Smoky flavor whilst they
rest spoon over some of the remaining
anchovy dressing
the chicken cools down the flavor the
seasoning of the anchovy the garlic and
the parmesan seeps into that chicken
slice the chicken into strips
wow
I serve the chicken warm in a separate
Bowl so it doesn't Wilt the salad spoon
the dressing
finish that with a little touch of
dressing
an American classic
I think one of the most popular sellers
anywhere in the world but it's still the
most delicious
[Music]
when it comes to lunch this really is an
American Dream a delicious Caesar salad
and succulent Golden Griddle chicken
with peanut butter and jam cookies for
dessert
when it comes to cooking techniques
barbecue is virtually a religion in
America especially in the southern
states down there the real barbecue Pros
use big open fire pits to get huge
joints of meat super succulent and
fantastically perfume with smoke and
spice so my ultimate American dinner has
to include an amazing melt-in-the-mouth
barbecue beef but I'm doing it the easy
way cooked in the oven low and slow
my family I spent a lot of time in the
US and they love American food
joining me in the kitchen today is
Jack's twin sister Holly we're creating
barbecue style beef brisket with crunchy
coleslaw and sweet potato wedges which
will be right up her Street
Holly
now
you love barbecues right
so you're gonna help me barbecue this
delicious piece of brisket brisket
look at it beautiful it was a very tough
cut of meat so it needs to be cooked
slowly so it gets really nice and tender
barbecuing it outside we're going to
actually put the barbecue flavor on
there but we're going to cook it in the
oven okay so mustard powder okay here we
have some celery seed next
a little bit of salt in there
okay what's this here cumin two again
nice good now this one
cayenne pepper absolutely right right
two teaspoons of that in there as well
because now what I want you to do
fresh pepper on there
I'll give that a little mix roll up your
little sleeves and then
I want you
to rub
all that spice into the brisket
almost like you're massaging it in there
good girl come on holes get your hands
nice and flat on there good girl
now that's nice and coated okay
in the spice SO gas on roasting tray on
what we've got to do now with all those
spices is sear them in a couple of
tablespoons of olive oil into the tray
well done okay that's getting nice and
hot now you get your brisket
and all that spice
throw that in there nicely okay so now
we'll start coloring it
as you start to sear in you smell those
spices yep all that spice left on the
plate
we're gonna use yeah
I want you to get the onions
nice and carefully slice them down not
too thin
but just like you're chopping them take
your time
foreign
spices now
good girl thank you
damn Holly
was homework that bad no the onions oh
no don't rub your eyes don't rub your
eyes
we've got the color
look on the brisket okay yeah
yeah take that out literally for 30
seconds okay onions into the tray please
nice
you see it started to smell slightly
barbecuing already give that a little
stir
nice now one nice tablespoon of brown
sugar
what does the brown sugar do that so the
brown sugar you're gonna start
caramelizing the onions
right from there my Bailey's in please
good girl yes please right we'll take
over
careful that tray is very very hot
a tablespoon of tomato puree roast that
off at the bottom of the tray you can
really rub it in amongst the onions good
girl
now look at the color of those onions
right now time for a little drink
for the brisket
okay one bottle of beer in please so you
go in you put yours in there I'll put
mine here good health to you and your
brisket
good health
bring that to the ball okay now this is
where it gets really exciting I want you
to lift the brisket up and put it on top
of the onions and she goes
good girl
and then I want you to pour the stock
all the way around please
I'm using beef stock but it will work
with chicken stock or even vegetable
stock
once the stock has come to the boil
cover tightly with foil and just pinch
in the ends
bend that down and then you just twist
all the way
so that's nice and tight that's the hard
work done thank you
simply pop it in the oven for three and
a half hours and as it Cooks you can get
on with the side dishes
first job sweet potato wedges with some
serious flavor
start by making a spice mix in a dry pan
toast coriander seeds until beautifully
aromatic
then put them in a pestle and mortar add
salt and grind
[Music]
next smoke paprika dried oregano cayenne
pepper and mix spice mix done now simply
cut your sweet potatoes into wedges toss
in olive oil and thoroughly cover with
the spice mix
onto a baking tray and into a preheated
oven for 30 minutes turning halfway
irresistible sweet potato wedgies are
ready now to finish off my beef
see that smell just sort of travels
everywhere
oh now look at that so we can leave that
to rest what does resting mean resting
means where you've cooked a joint and
you just leave it to relax so it'll make
the meat so much more tender okay right
coleslaw traditionally you would mix
slaw with what mayonnaise that's right
mayonnaise this time we're gonna do it a
little different so I'd like to put the
yogurt into the bowl for me
place all of it I'll start slicing the
white cabbage
and the red cabbage now from there a
nice tablespoon
of mustard in there please give that a
nice mix up
nice little touch of salt and pepper
okay
now
a little cider vinegar so a little
splash of cider vinegar in there okay as
I shred this okay I'd like you please
then to get the
red cabbage and just open up into that
and mix it in at the same time and then
you fold that in there as I start
shredding
see how it's coming together yeah
right that's all the red cabbage now for
the white
so got that nice vinegary tartness for
the slaw and the yogurt keeps it nice
and fresh
last little bit in
one more little thing
so
it was a nice
chopped fresh chives in there and that
will give it this nice light
onion flavor
so chives in
how's that now taste it with the chives
in there
delicious so
like you
to fill up the bowl I'm going to very
carefully lift out my brisket how come
junk it's been in the oven
for nearly three and a half hours so
it's been cooked slowly
that sits on there oh my goodness me let
me just show you what this looks like
and start slicing it and see how soft
look at that
and here's the thing about helping daddy
cook
here's the perk
you get to taste it first before anybody
that is so good that
taste
delicious see all that wonderful flavor
in there last job is to create an
incredibly quick and delicious sauce
and reduce the spicy juices and onions
the beef cooked in then add inside of
vinegar and you add a brilliant Tangy
barbecue sauce
smells nice
brisket
now the rest of it
should go in the gravy pot
and that's a really nice rich
spicy
barbecue
onion gravy
that my darling is the perfect way
to serve brisket right you ready
if you carry
the sweet potato for me I've got the
brisket wow
let's go Donnie well done by the way
thank you this is a real American Beauty
gorgeous low and slow cooked barbecue
beef brisket with three potato wedges
and yogurt coleslaw
Megan Jack hi Tilly big deep Smoky
flavors that bring the taste of the
American South to your kitchen
who'd like some coleslaw I'd love
and who'd like some gravy thank you but
it's spicy and slightly barbecue how's
the brisket really good
it's amazing
with the gravy
and what do you think
the
capabilities
in Vista
I'm pretty good you think so yeah if
you're not as good as mine but I can
feel
a lot of competition
in amongst the Ramsay girls good job
thank you there are loads more great
home cooking recipes on my app cook with
me you can find it in the App Store good
luck